i
[Música]
ah
en brasil hay cerca de 10 millones de
descendientes de sirios y libaneses
según datos de la federación de
asociaciones musulmanas de ellos tan
solo un millón y medio de personas
practican la religión musulmana
incluyendo los refugiados que han
llegado en los últimos años a brasil
muchos descendientes de esta comunidad
abrazaron hace generaciones la religión
católica es el caso del ex presidente de
brasil michel temer y del ex candidato a
la presidencia fernando haddad este año
por segundo año consecutivo las
mezquitas permanecerán cerradas debido a
la pandemia y el elevado número de
muertes en brasil en este momento la
indicación de la federación es que el
ramadán se celebre en casa a ser posible
con pocos familiares para evitar
aglomeraciones además por segundo año
consecutivo se lanzará una distribución
de alimentos a personas necesitadas el
año pasado fueron recogidas 150
toneladas de comida
[Música]
se estima que entre 25 mil y 30 mil
musulmanes residen en colombia en todo
el territorio nacional sin embargo las
comunidades más numerosas se concentran
en bogotá la capital del país y en el
municipio de maicao en el norte de esta
nación por segundo año consecutivo las
familias musulmanas celebrarán la
ruptura del ayuno pilar de esta
ceremonia solamente con su núcleo
familiar no obstante a diferencia del
año pasado en este 2021 si podrán acudir
a las mezquitas no obstante deberán
regirse por las normas de bioseguridad
como mantener una distancia de 2 metros
entre los asistentes algunos templos
piden sin embargo que los mayores de 70
años así como los enfermos con algunas
dolencias crónicas o severas se
abstengan de asistir a las ceremonias en
bogotá la capital del país
además se rige la entrada a los templos
por la medida del pico y cédula que
determina la entrada a algunos espacios
públicos por el último dígito del
documento de identidad de cada ciudadano
[Música]
durante el mes del noveno mes del
calendario islámico los fieles
musulmanes congregados en cinco
mezquitas alrededor del país se reunirán
diariamente tras la puesta del sol para
orar y romper el ayuno con comidas
típicas salvadoreñas como mangos o
frutas de temporada en almíbar así como
platillos tradicionales asociados con la
celebración las reuniones tendrán lugar
tanto en línea como en persona si bien
no existe un registro oficial se estima
que aproximadamente 4000 personas
practican la fe musulmana en el salvador
la primera mezquita fue fundada en 1993
por armando book el líder espiritual de
la comunidad musulmana y padre del
actual presidente del país nadie bukele
desde 2015 de su hermano emerson bukele
fue nombrado por la comunidad islámica
árabe salvadoreña como imán o líder de
la congregación en seguimiento al legado
de su padre actualmente encabeza la
comunidad islámica hispanoamericana el
año pasado durante la cuarentena por
cody 19 el presidente buque le decretó
el día nacional de la oración el cual
coincidía con el último día del ramadán
del 2020
[Música]